right Donnie listen to me now we're
gonna start assembling in the Sun yeah
hey hey look girls
come on Johnny stay with me first
look okay for that I need you listen to
me it's a little bit of milk in there
okay tablespoon of milk it gives her a
nice little sweetness and more
importantly enriches it bay leaf out
okay now half the minutes half an inch
once you are half in there come on
Johnny stay with me aren't good now take
your sheets of lasagna
okay okay and place them on top of the
mints now don't overlap okay
no you don't want to do the cooking time
yeah home please stay with me not like
this man shocking yet but you'll overlap
okay
get your sauce but half the sort of top
okay so hard trying to take the sauce
over here right then from there the
other half you mince back on top of the
white sauce now from there
get work sheets of lasagna make sure
they don't overlap okay push that down
/ hey that won't work
Russ
man the rest of the sauce on top
now once you've coated the top of the
Fanny with a cheese sauce okay we're
gonna take this time Parmesan cheese
keep going
yeah I just move out well done done it
yeah
keep up with Nikki well I do overlap
okay now finally Parmesan okay onto the
top I may get the rest of your Agana
google that on top okay now that goes in
the oven twenty minutes twenty
twenty-five degrees gas mark 7